[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues madame la
Présidente de commission madame mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs ça y est on y
est alors on va tuer le suspense
majoritairement très majoritairement
notre groupe votre race ce texte on y
est un peu fatigué d'avoir travaillé un
peu fatigué aussi de vous avoir écouté
mes chers collègues
mais on aborde cette fin de discussion
sans regrets sans remords avec une
sérénité un soulagement un soulagement
pour la place et la crédibilité du Sénat
un soulagement pour notre système de
retraite par répartition un soulagement
pour la démocratie
représentative voilà nous sommes au bout
du texte comme nous l'avait dit le
président vous n'avez pas été pris par
surprise c'était un engagement qui avait
exprimé le Sénat et son président est il
a été capitaine dans la tempête le Sénat
et son président et la majorité
sénatoriale ont tenu leur objectif je
veux remercier à mon tour les présidents
de groupe pour l'organisation des débats
les rapporteurs un formidable
en argumentation ayant travaillé faisant
notre fierté des batteurs infatigables
ça lui aussi les groupes d'opposition
ils ont fait le choix de la flibusterie
oh disons-le c'était une flibusterie de
notable ça va pas forcément vous faire
plaisir mais c'est ainsi mes chers
collègues
alors ce texte
ce texte
il mérite pas l'indignation que vous lui
avez prêté il mérite pas non plus un
enthousiasme excessif ça n'est pas la
mère des réformes mais il a une utilité
une exigence morale pour les jeunes
générations une utilité parce que
c'était nécessaire alors je vais vous
lire un texte
il n'y a pas d'alternative de nouveaux
efforts notamment des départs à la
retraite plus tardif devront être
réalisés afin de pérenniser notre
système de retraite
je vais répéter on a beaucoup écouté ce
matin on font la rien la chair rien
lâchez rien lâcher on revendique à notre
tour le droit à la répétition
et la répétition c'est l'art de la
pédagogie alors il n'y a pas
d'alternative de nouveaux efforts
notamment des départs à la retraite plus
tardif devront être réalisés afin de
pérenniser notre système de retraite
quelle est cette hauteur un affreux
réactionnel un conservateur un
rétrograde c'est un nom qui sonne à vos
oreilles c'est Pierre Moscovici mes
chers collègues un thermoscovici et donc
et lui revendique l'héritage de la
social-démocratie on a entendu beaucoup
de bêtises parfois sur cette dans cette
hémicycle mais je crois que là tout à
l'heure on a touché le fond
pardonnez-moi l'amour des chiffres
ne peut pas faire bon ménage avec
l'amour des gens alors là excusez-moi
j'ai entendu ça tout à l'heure voilà la
responsabilité c'est qu'elle sait
l'amour des chiffres et c'est l'amour
des gens et je pense que vous avez cité
Pierre Mauroy si Jacques Delore avait
entendu que l'amour des chips était
incompatible avec l'amour des gens je
pense qu'il aurait réagi dans cette
assemblée c'est un soulagement pour nos
systèmes de retraite un soulagement pour
les retraités parce que évidemment il y
a ceux qui manifestent mais il y a aussi
minorité majorité je sais pas
silencieuse les retraités qui après le
vote de ce texte sont sécurisés par
rapport à leur retraite et par rapport
leur risque qui pouvait y avoir sur la
baisse des retraites les jeunes qui vont
pas devoir payer deux fois une double
peine payer leur retraite mais aussi
payer la dette parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
y a de plus irresponsable que de payer
les dettes à crédit nous ne faisons pas
ce choix du paiement des dettes à crédit
c'est irresponsable
ce texte ça a été dit il y a des
avancées les seniors le CDI seniors bien
sûr que le travail plus longtemps pour
les seniors c'est la clé ça a été dit
par Elisabeth par une épaule la question
des familles des carrières longues la
politique familiale la question de
l'égalité homme-femme les tuques chers
collègues faudra pas en ayant pas voté
steaks revendiquer des avantages ou une
justice pour l'étude les pompiers mes
chers collègues et puis les élus grâce à
Sylvie vermeiller les mers et les élus
pourront et c'est pas voir les choses
par le petit bout de la lorgnette
excusez-moi pourront racheter des
trimestres pour les élus qui gagnent
moins de 1830 euros par mois mais ce
texte n'est pas un chèque en blanc il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'il faudra
aborder la question de la justice bien
sûr cette réforme des retraites ne peut
pas tout la question du sens du travail
on n'est pas acharné on croit la valeur
travail mais bien évidemment il faut la
qualité de de vie au travail il faut la
formation tout au long de la vie il faut
travailler sur l'autonomie il faut une
grande loi travail nous sommes partisans
de cette grande loi travail et puis il
faut un dialogue social
et ça nous y tenons beaucoup un
paritarisme rénové refondé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec Hervé
Marseille nous demandons l'ouverture le
plus vite possible d'une conférence
sociale et puis si soulager par et pour
la démocratie représentative les
institutions de la 5e sont solides tant
mieux mes chers collègues parce que sans
ces articles on n'y serait pas arrivé
vous savez Aristote disait la politique
c'est la rhétorique mais c'est aussi
l'action et la délibération et donc
l'obstruction parlementaire c'est une
impasse ah encore un affreux
réactionnaire c'est Laurent Berger qui
dit ça
alors il y aura un avant et un après on
a entendu un avant et un après mais oui
mais surtout sur votre banc on a cité
tout à l'heure Alfred Jarry les vorace
et les curiasses et bien oui mes chers
collègues les voraces ont battu les
coriaces comme dans Alfred Jarry mais
c'est la gauche radicale qui a écrasé la
sociale démocratie dans vos rangs voilà
la réalité de ce débat et c'est en ça
que plus rien ne sera pareil on a eu
donc une gauche sur rassembler sur le
plus petit dénominateur commun celui de
la radicalité alors pour conclure je
voudrais citer Charles de Gaulle la
politique la plus coûteuse les chers
collègues la plus ruineuse pour le
peuple c'est d'être petit et bien cette
citation je vous l'envoie en cadeau le
Sénat sort renforcé les institutions
sont solides la démocratie
représentative est plus crédible et nous
sommes fiers les uns et les autres
d'appartenir à cette majorité
sénatoriale je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président François
Patriat pour